You know what I love?  Being productive.
Being productive isn't hard.  It just takes a little thought.
So first off, if you don't have a Life Map for 2016, make that right now.
This is your big picture.  It's your goals, it's your dreams, and everything you hope to accomplish in the new year.
Next, you're going to break down each of those things into executable actions.
I do this with all of my big productions.  It's where you list each step
that needs to be taken in order to accomplish your goal.
Now, taking these steps is not going to be that hard.
But focusing on taking these steps probably will be.
This is when you have to learn how to work smart instead of hard.
And distribute your energy and efforts to the tasks that are going to bring you the most reward.
For example, I used to riddle my To-Do List with meaningless tasks
like clean the cat litter, or do laundry.  Simply because I was addicted to the feeling of accomplishment that I got
when I crossed it off.
Oh.  That feels good.
(excited shudder)
Plus, even if I didn't do the most important things I had to do that day
I still felt good seeing that I did something.
But if you only write down imperative tasks--the ones that would create some real progress in your work
you'll notice exactly how much you're getting done.
Or not.
Some people also find writing a To-Not-Do List helpful.
This helps remind them that they don't want to succumb to time-wasting tasks
like refreshing social media or watching TV
at least when it's not scheduled break time.
The best thing you can do for long-term productivity is to create a Daily Ritual
That way you're productive on auto-pilot.
Next, learn how to say no.  This is something that I still personally struggle with.
You know, I want to do everything.  I want to take every opportunity--you never know what's going to lead to what!
But remember the Life Map.
Keep your eye on the prize.  If you say yes to a bunch of projects that don't give you great results
that's wasted time.
Stop multi-tasking!
Multi-tasking is just a fancy word for being bad at everything you're doing.
Don't neglect execise and healthy eating.
That's your energy.
Kill distractions!
If you really need to write, I recommend going out of the house and turning off your Wifi.
And there are plenty of programs online that you can install that will block social media sites
for certain hours of the day.
Now this is all stuff we know, right?
Spend less time on the internet, get more done--this isn't new.
But sometimes it's good to hear.
It's good to have that reminder of all the things we know we should be doing.
I mean you probably clicked on this video because you wanted to sort of feel like you were kinda doing something.
Right?
Wrong.
So get off Youtube, and get to work.
Thank you for waiting.
And thank you to Audible for sponsoring today's episode.
Audible.com is the leading provider of audiobooks.
With over 180,000 titles to choose from
across all types of literature.
I like listening to audiobooks when I'm commuting to the hospital or washing my lab coat at the end of the day.
Currently, I'm listening to "Getting Things Done" by David Allen
because I want to increase my productivity on diagnosing patients like yourself
while simultaneously juggling my ground breaking cancer research
Right now Audible is offering a free 30 day trial
for people like you to give you a chance to try out their service.
So I'd like you to go to Audible.com/Anna to download a free trial and start listening.
That's Audible.com/Anna
Just what the doctor ordered.
(chuckling)